In an action film the list of stunt men and
women can go longer than the list of credits
for actors.
These roles are important to the safety of
the cast and crew but sometimes movie stars
want to perform their own stunts.
These stunts can go terrible wrong and cause
long-term damage to the stars but nonetheless
they continue to want to perform them.
Sometimes these stunt could be a simple turn
around that anyone of us can do but when you’re
on a film set things can get dangerous.
Get ready to like Screen Rant’s list of
ten Movie Stunts That Weren't Suppose To Go
Horribly Wrong.
Bruce Willis in Die Hard
This action packed film that spawned a holiday
movie-watching tradition, almost made Bruce
Willis deaf.
After Alan Rickman’s Hans Gruber and gang
took over the Nakatomi corporation building
one man stood in the way of them stealing
$640 million in bearer bonds, Willis’ John
McClane.
When Willis fired a gun, the sound of the
gun going off was compressed due to his location
under a desk.
He went deaf in one ear, only getting back
45% of his hearing.
It must not have fazed Willis since he keeps
making Die Hard sequels.
Charlize Theron in Aeon Flux
Charlize Theron has given her all for her
films, which is why she has an Oscar and has
starred in some awesome action films.
While performing in Aeon Flux, Theron knew
her role would be physical and she felt she
was prepared due to her training as a professional
ballet dancer.
While performing a back handspring Theron
came down on her neck and sustained a spinal
disc herniation and massive nerve damage.
Five days in the hospital and weeks of physical
therapy taught Theron to leave the more difficult
stunts to her stunt doubles.
Jackie Chan in Armour of God
You are probably not surprised that Jackie
Chan is on this list but the surprise is he
won’t stop performing stunts and honestly
we don’t want him to.
Chan has slide down the side of a skyscraper,
free fell 60 feet and has even been hit by
a helicopter in flight.
Still his worst injury came in 1991’s Armour
of God with a stunt that wasn’t nearly as
dangerous.
He was supposed to jump from a slope and into
a tree but he missed and hit his head on a
rock, causing a piece of his skull to go into
his brain.
That must’ve been the part of the brain
that enhances fear because Chan knows no fear.
Diane Kruger in Inglorious Bastards
The Inglourious Basterds recruit German film
star Bridget von Hammersmark, played by Diane
Kruger, to infiltrate a movie premiere in
an attempt to kill Hitler and other top Nazi
officials.
Sadly Kruger’s character is killed before
the deed is finished in a realistic strangulation
scene.
That’s because the director Quentin Tarrantino
convinced Kruger to be strangled-for real!
Realistic, yes but he could’ve given her
a chance to try acting before cutting off
her air supply in that dangerous stunt.
Steve Carell in The 40 Year Old Virgin
One of the most memorable scenes from The
40 Year Old Virgin is when Steve Carell gets
his chest waxed.
Some can say this isn’t a stunt but normally
close ups would be shot by a stunt double
and not the lead actor.
Carell decided it would be funnier if he got
waxed himself and not have a stunt double
take his place.
The director used four cameras to ensure no
retakes would be needed because he knew Carell
wouldn’t want to do it again.
We are thankful Carell decided to become a
Man O’Lantern!
Halle Berry in Many Of Her Films
Halle Berry is not someone you want to stand
near while working on a movie set.
She has had multiple injuries on multiple
films and seems to not be getting any better.
While filming Gothika she broke her arm, then
on the set of Catwoman she hit her head on
a lighting rig, but it doesn’t stop there.
She broke her foot on Cloud Atlas and during
the film, The Call she smacked her head on
the floor.
Still, her most embarrassing moment came from
the film Die Another Day when she choked on
a fig during a sex scene with Pierce Bronson.
Yes, we said fig, get your mind out of the
gutter.
Michael J. Fox in Back to the Future Part
III
After three Back to the Future films you would
think Michael J. Fox would be used to his
Marty character being harassed by the Tannen’s.
Yet, during the filming of Back to the Future
Part III he almost lost his life.
In the scene where Mad Dog Tannen hanged him,
he decided to perform his own stunt.
In rehearsals all went well but when it came
time to the actually shoot he was asphyxiated
and lost consciousness.
No one realized it until a crewmember realized
his acting was a little too good and they
luckily cut him down.
Jennifer Lawrence in The Hunger Games: Mockingjay
– Part 1
She’s one of the hardest working actresses
in Hollywood and she demands the same pay
as her male co-stars.
That’s because she deserve it.
Not only does she bring in the ticket sales
but during the making of The Hunger Games:
Mockingjay – Part 1 she was injured twice.
During training she ran into a wall injuring
herself and when filming with a smoke machine
the machine broke and she was covered in smoke.
She almost choked to death but luckily she
survived and had no permanent injuries.
Jeremy Renner in The Avengers
Jeremy Renner opted out of using a stunt man
for many of the action scenes in "The Avengers."
In the shot where he jumped from a two-story
building, turned and shoot a bow and arrow
toward the camera-it was actually Renner.
His impressive skills were used throughout
the film until he turned the wrong way during
a fight and blew out his back.
This injury is still with him today and now
he looks for a stunt double to take his place
in the more aggressive scenes.
Harrison Ford in Star Wars: Episode VII – The
Force Awakens
Harrison Ford has survived a plane crash and
the wrath of a movie prop all in the same
year.
When the Millennium Falcon’s door landed
on then 71-year-old Ford, it broke his leg
and caused other severe injuries.
The studio responsible was fined 2 million
dollars, even though Ford wasn’t upset at
all.
He was joking and trying to keep others calm
as he waited for them to lift the door off
him.
They should have called Chewbacca over to
help!
What do you think of our video?
Did we skip over any of your favorite movie
stunts that went horrible wrong?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more fun videos!
Thanks for watching!